obviously you've had such an incredible
career and
uh and i'm acting like it we're wrapping
it up your career
um uh you are uh you're just killing it
out there all the time
but you know i'm always impressed with
you're such a
very and it's not maybe the first thing
people would think of but you're so
naturally funny you're a very funny guy
and i always notice that when we chat
and and when i bump into you
and i thought has he ever used that
before earlier in his life
and then i found out that you tried
stand-up in high school
what was your act like i foolishly did
do that
um i was with the friend who is as
ridiculous as i was and we thought
we could probably do this we were
driving by larimer square i
think the comedy is a comedy store
there's some right place spot there and
they had an open mic night
and it was friday night and we had just
had a week of whatever at school
we thought you know what we're theater
geeks we could probably
do this so we went back to my house and
we had a bunch of you know
cards and died we we our humor was like
we diagnosed the humor of nancy the
comic strip nancy
we're just saying nancy and slugo that's
right the
the comic that no one has ever really
been able i think henry bush miller did
that comic and it doesn't make sense
no it's objectively unfunny there's
nothing
funny about it so we diagnosed the humor
of nancy for everybody it explained why
it was indeed
hilarious uh we did uh a series of pope
francis
jokes with him on the [ __ ] and a
bishop holding his hat
while he told the worst jokes in the
world okay great
great so you have the material let's
face it you had the material we had the
material i don't know how but we had it
and we went back that night and you know
we're too young to be in the club we're
17 years old
uh but we did it and it was great we had
it worked it worked
wow so the club owner was like okay why
don't you guys come back next friday
we're gonna have another open mic see
how you like it just try it out so we
did and
worked up a bunch of other material and
uh
a game show where you know if you got
the answers wrong the consequences were
deadly not just you know
like right reaching the bag and get bit
by an asp it was like stuff like that
right uh killed again he was like this
is incredible
this was incredible you could have had
an amazing career and
what happened here then we did it again
oh
there you go what happened the third
time well uh
in front of an invited audience of
family and friends and
and others uh it didn't go as well
and the collective sound of individual
people groaning
the groan that like it was pretty bad
yeah
so we we bombed and i've never felt
anything that
horrible it's bombing on stage and stan
there's nowhere to hide there's nowhere
to pass the ball you just have to stand
there
you're praying that the time is is up
really quickly you can't walk off
it was just bad i don't know what you're
talking about
never happened to you you know what i
always say is when you can hear the air
conditioning
that when i can hear the air
conditioning and sometimes it gets so
quiet you can hear
cells dividing in people like bloop
and uh it is uh the most horrible thing
is so
that night and it's interesting because
your first two times
you're killing it yeah and then it's
that third time where this sort of
reality sets in if this is not what it
will always be like
right yes this is not what it will be
like for the next three minutes while
you have to stand up here
and it was so bad it's like you know on
the way home my parents didn't talk
about it at all we talked about other
things
right didn't mention it like yeah that
that's that's that's not that's
that's death when you get in a car after
a show and people that were there
don't say anything no they just say so
we want to get something to eat
exactly let's just move on to you can we
talk about what just happened back there
i don't
i don't think i don't think so i don't
think you want that do you you
come from a funny uh family is your mom
funny mom was funny
dad was funny mom was you know mom was
funny slash dangerous it's like you know
my mom
grew up and both my parents are from
small towns in midwest but
my mom grew up in kind of a bad area and
uh when she was young she actually
carried a gun she carried a little
38th oh wow i found going through her
stuff and
you know i gingerly asked her about the
gun you know and she said oh yeah i've
had that gun for a long time i carried
it when i was young but i
had to stop carrying it and i said why
she said because excuse me turned into
move
i was like okay
that is some experience isn't it i'm
just going through mom's purse
oh lipstick and compact and 38 38
i guess i'm gonna listen when mom asked
me to do something